how many times is the Lord brought him
back six cornerstone Costas Tower
hey youtubers is Charlie so time to talk
about resurrection in the game of
Thrones universe or Song of Ice and Fire
and a lot of you had questions after the
season 5 finale so I'm going to do a
breakdown of all the resurrections we've
seen on the show and their methods also
heads up the giveaway that I announced
in my in my last video is still going on
it's a $20 Amazon gift card all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner my Q&A video so
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on the show here we go
thus far we have seen 3 different types
of resurrection for if you want to get
really technical but really it's three
there's the White Walkers in the night's
king raising White's
there's Thor oh so mere resurrecting
beric Dondarrion using prayers the red
God Thoros also refers to this as giving
the kiss of life although I think he
only uses that terminology in the books
later beric Dondarrion gives his life
force to another person even though it
probably involves some of the same
mechanisms you could look at that is the
same type of resurrection from the right
god and then three we have Qyburn
raising the mountain on his table here
frankenstein style so i want to start
with this quote from Thoreau Samir is it
it is really nice quote I'm gonna omit
some spoilery parts of it Harlan begged
me to give her the kiss of life but it
had been too long and I would not do it
so Lord beric put his lips to hers
instead in the flame of life passed from
him to her and she rose may the Lord of
Light protect us she rose so he's
[ __ ] his pants a little when he says
that he has absolutely no idea how the
red God brought these people back from
the dead or what he did to make it
happen on the TV show he explains it a
little bit better he just says I asked
and the red God does what he wants he
brings him back or he doesn't
so really Thoreau's has absolutely no
idea what's going on
and neither does Melisandre the red God
could grant people life because they're
important to his cause or some other
reason we have no idea I like that idea
though the flame of life the way Thoreau
is refers to it makes it sound like it's
an actual physical thing
George R Martin has offered no
explanation about how it works but I
think we have a little more context to
understand the magic of the White
Walkers so let's move on to them even
though people on social media
affectionately call these ice zombies
they're White's both are reanimated
corpses but the difference is zombie
aren't mentally controlled by another
person they're not remote-controlled
whites are kind of like glorified finger
puppets with white walkers pulling the
strings and I know in Episode eight
it was the night's king that ordered
them into battle and raised up a bunch
of new ones but any white Walker can do
that it's kind of hard to tell but
because the night's king here isn't
saying anything he just raises his arms
and they come up from the dead it seems
like there's no prayer involved like he
just has the magic innately within him
Thoros can't do that in the books he has
to give Barrack the kiss of life meaning
he literally has to put his lips on his
barek does the same thing later to bring
another character back to life but you
could call that um almost invoking a
blessing the way like a cleric in
traditional fantasy literature calls
down a blessing from their God to give
them power for a brief period when a
white Walker raises a white though the
white is completely under their control
and as we learned in season 4 episode 10
from mr. Skelton here White's don't have
to be freshly deceased the night's king
could just dig up the skeleton of the
Mad King and add him to the army the
dead would that be fun and everybody
wants to see Ned Stark back he could
technically be made part of the army of
the Dead even though technically the
show hasn't promised this to us I feel
like it would be amazing if we were to
see characters that have died off on the
show
brought back by the night's king and
made part of the army of the dead just
like a little patchy Ned Stark skeleton
for those of you that read comic books
it'd be a lot like blackest night where
a lot of DC's dead characters were
resurrected as black Lantern's in major
contrast to that though when priests of
the red God resurrect someone there
they're basically just reversing death
so the person you get back is almost
exactly like themselves before they died
the caveat being that the longer they've
been dead in the more gruesome the
method of their death the less they are
when they come back the less of their
original selves beric Dondarrion gets
brought back six times when we meet him
in his sixth self here in season three
episode six
he's a shadow of his former self he
barely has any memories from before the
war of the five kings but still remember
that quote that I read from Thoreau's he
said that he would not bring back that
other person and Barrack did it instead
meaning that he could continue to bring
people
fact that had been dead for even longer
periods of time it's just that they
would be like monsters but both the
White Walkers and the priests of the red
God form of necromancy raising the dead
even though the red priests were really
reversing death rather than raising the
dead what about Frankenstein Qyburn
though what he's doing slightly
different but also form of necromancy
you have to remember his history he was
training at the Citadel but was kicked
out because he was performing freakish
experiments or what the arch masters
thought of as being freakish he wanted
to be the best healer there ever was so
he started opening the living to learn
the secrets of death which is really
what physicians nowadays do I mean like
you're sick they open you up to see
what's wrong and then they fix you the
arch maesters not having it so they
kicked him out he lost his chain but
what I think Qyburn has done is combined
a lot of arcane knowledge from the
Citadel with practical healing methods
enough so that there might be some
mystical aspects to what he did but for
the most part you could call it science
the books really don't offer a whole lot
of details as to how that is hopefully
wins a winner will spell that out a
little bit better but it's also implied
that he performs experiments on pregnant
women and all manner of other creepy
things you know it's just the tip of the
iceberg he has all kinds of crazy
experiments going on in the black cells
the important thing though is that
during season 4 when he was talking to
Cersei about bringing them out and back
he said that the process would change
him we don't know the full extent of his
abilities you know but based on what
we've seen he works more like a golem he
has limited function and he can respond
to commands but he doesn't need to eat
and as far as we know he can't speak
what does all this have to do with
season 6 well it means that death isn't
the end is just the beginning
there have been resurrections many times
in the past in the books and on the show
they will continue to happen that's why
so many people so many book readers and
now show people think that Jon Snow is
coming back even though it doesn't
happen all the time
resurrection not the craziest thing
we've seen them do there are a whole lot
of other structural narrative reasons
book readers think that Jon Snow is
going to come back but if you've only
been watching the show you've only seen
a few clues so I want to get too crazy
with the book stuff but as much as the
show changes there's no way that George
R Martin would point Jon Snow's
character in a certain direction
and the show would change that dead are
not dead they wouldn't change that from
the books there are a whole lot of
theories about how he might survive you
know but if he does Dan and Dave would
also be compelled to save him that being
said I know everyone's asking what's the
deal with kid Harrington and the
producer saying that John Snow is dead
and he's not coming back there are two
big theories one they're intentionally
lying to heighten the WTF whenever he
does come back and two they're just
they're using slippery lawyer speak as
in John Snow does come back but he's
fundamentally changed in the process
therefore the John snow we knew does not
come back even though Kit Harington the
actor does you can also think in a
different direction to John snow doesn't
come back in season six or at least just
briefly in Episode one is like a follow
up like someone finds his dead body in
the snow his body gets drugged off a
frame and he just doesn't show up again
until season seven he gets fridge for an
entire season like branded that would be
really weird but it is totally possible
here's my big question for you guys
given that bringing characters back from
the dead is such a regular thing and
there are a lot of clues that Jon Snow
is a very critical character do you feel
like Dan and Dave are deceiving fans to
just you know try and misdirect us and
if so how long do you think they can
keep that up like do you think that they
can keep this up for an entire year
while they film all of next season if
Kit Harington is going to be on set
someone is going to spot him Game of
Thrones starts filming really soon so
even if you know we don't expect a lot
of Jon Snow in season six I still think
they could film a couple scenes with
them and remember Comic Con is coming up
really soon - they could be planning
something really special I'm not
expecting them to do any special Jon
Snow stuff but I do feel like they
should bring Kit Harington they brought
Pedro Pascal right after Oberyn Martell
got his head squished like a grape so
they bring dead actors to Comic Con like
they brought Jason Momoa just
speculation you have to remember you
know book readers have been living with
this trying to figure this out for the
last four or five years and the books do
offer a few more clues as to why Jon
Snow is such an important character like
it's not one of those George R Martin
things where he just Yanks the rug out
from under you just to remind you guys
I'm doing a Q&A this week I'm also doing
a Star Wars rebels video and a lot of
you guys were asking for that so anyway
for all that you can click here to learn
all about the season six cast that
they're trying to land right now they're
going to now
some of that at comic-con and you can
click here to learn all about Ozora high
in the night's king thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow